i work for wolfram alpha  but i also do some data science projects  on the side as well that display  that was in my car was keeping track of  much more information that  i really wondered how am i going to get  to that information because i really  want that  i have an arduino that is connected to  my car's can bus or the obd2 port as  it's called  and the nice thing about is that all  devices can hear  all devices messages i keep track of the  price and uh where they are and that  kind of stuff and probably most  interesting that i found was the  fuel flow so i've done some need  analysis with like trends  per month but i have been collecting a  lot of data as i travel around and stuff  like that so yeah in the future i think  what i want to do is uh  learn driving patterns and analyze the  actual paths through  which i drive so just ready to show  people how to use wolfram language for  data science projects and other things  too  you